l'est du pays le port de marioupol lui
résiste toujours malgré des
bombardements incessants et des combats
urbains quelques 350 mille habitants
restent toujours coincés là bas dans des
conditions dramatiques on va partir à
présent à odessa le plus grand port du
pays pour la première fois hier les
faubourgs de la ville ont été touchés
par des frappes on retrouve sur place
notre envoyé spécial julie daniela et je
me trouve à 20 minutes du centre ville
d'odessa qui a été touchée hier dans la
maison de cet homme de 81 ans qui nous a
décrit la scène qu'il a vécu hier il a
entendu des bombardements une maison
touchée une autre touche et puis il
s'est dit la prochaine ce sera la mienne
eh bien c'est ce qui s'est passé sa
maison vous le voyez toutes les vitres
son souffle et une partie de la façade a
été emporté par les bombardements il a
pu se réfugier cette nuit chez des
voisins qui l'héberge il nous décrivait
une scène assez apocalyptique 1 où il ne
pensait jamais et bien que les russes
attaquerait des habitations il se disait
qu'il était à l'abri ne croyait pas par
exemple et bien que sa maison pourrait
finir dans un tel état il pensait que
seuls des bâtiments militaires étaient
touchés cet homme qui n'a pas de mots
assez forts contre vladimir poutine qui
me disait que il le comparer au diable
tant il y avait de souffrance ici à au
dessin est un peu plus loin on est
vraiment au bord de la mer noire un peu
plus loin on peut voir d'autres
habitations qui ont été touchés dont les
toits ont été emportés les fenêtres ont
été emportées donc cela s'intensifie
autour d'eux c'est ça la pression
s'intensifie autour de rsa et cette nuit
on a pu entendre plusieurs sirène dans
la ville ces sirènes qui invite la
population à se mettre à l'abri en cas
de frappes aériennes julie hier vous
étiez amicaux life le dernier verrou
avant ce port d'odessa et les habitants
la barresi ce malgré des frappes qui
s'intensifie
oui l'armée ukrainienne semble résister
ces derniers jours selon les autorités
ukrainiennes eh bien ils ont réussi à
repousser les russes plus loin vers
personne cependant et bien hier les
bombardements se sont intensifiés aussi
amicaux la ive nous étions avec amar
alameda oui nous avons pu entendre de
nom bombardements nous avons pu nous
rendre sur les lieux de l'un d'entre eux
il s'agit d'un hôtel et d'une banque qui
a été considérablement endommagée par
une frappe aérienne par chance et bien
aucune victime n'est à déplorer une
personne a été légèrement blessée selon
les personnes avec lesquelles nous avons
pu parler mais les sirènes non sens
n'ont cessé de hurler dans la ville et
nous avons pu voir des habitants qui
étaient effrayés par ce qui se passait
qui tentaient de se mettre à l'abri
alors que d'autres et bien nous disait
être assez là c'est assez habitués
maintenant depuis près d'un mois et bien
que ces sirènes résonnent tous les jours
nous avons pu parler notamment à une
vieille femme qui se terraient dans sa
cave depuis près d'un mois car son
appartement bien n'avait plus de
fenêtres et le froid bien sûr ne lui
permettait pas de rester chez elles nous
avons pu parler à des pompiers qui nous
ont parlé de cette frappe très
meurtrière pour l'armée ukrainienne un
plus de 50 soldats sont morts vendredi
dans une frappe c est pompier qui
continuaient à déblayer le corps de
victimes qui pour certains étaient des
amis ses pompiers bien sûr épuisé et
effrayée par tout ce qu'ils avaient vécu
jusqu'à présent donc beaucoup de
pression sur cette ville de nicolas yves
également qui est souvent présenté comme
le dernier rempart avant une bataille de
plus grande ampleur sur odessa